what's up guys bang bang over the last
48 hours there has been a big
development in the recent 300 plus
million dollar hack in the crypto
industry now as a refresher remember
wormhole it's a bridge between ethereum
and solana there was somebody who went
in and hacked 120 000 ethereum that was
worth just over 300 million dollars now
the way that they were able to do it was
they essentially got into the software
they were able to find a bug and they
exploited it they stole the funds
jump capital just in the last 24 hours
came forward and said you know what
we're actually going to go ahead and
we're going to refund all 300 plus
million dollars for users jump capital
it's a high frequency trading firm based
in chicago they've been deep into crypto
people may not realize just how much
they actually dabble in the crypto
markets they've got about 140 people
working on crypto inside of the firm
they've been deploying billions of
dollars into the industry and so to see
them step in with over 300 million
dollars to actually go ahead and refund
users is pretty damn cool you really got
to just respect it and whether it's a
high frequency trading firm it's a
venture capital firm it'd be a legacy
wall street bank or an individual anyone
who's willing to put that type of dough
up to actually go ahead and refund users
gets my respect now why exactly are they
doing this well because jump capital
actually bought a company that is
partially responsible for wormhole the
development of that bridge so they do
have an economic interest in seeing this
be successful but also i don't think
that you just simply put 300 plus
million dollars to work just because you
have some economic interest you
obviously want crypto to be successful
you want the technologies to be
successful but the message to every
single person is this stuff's new it's
risky and you've got to be careful kudos
to jump capital for stepping in and
going ahead and refunding users 300
million dollars is nothing to thumb your
nose at but also as users you have to be
careful these bridges there's a lot of
promise to but they're still very very
risky so 300 million dollars got stolen
300 million dollars just gonna hand it
back to users pretty damn cool to watch
but be careful out there my friends and
i'll see you on the internet